[Music]  Jay Z Seinfeld is setting the record  straight about those pesky Justin Bieber  dating rumors now you are not dating  Justin Bieber right I am NOT no it's  crazy I don't know why people make sense  as we know Haley cleared it all up on  the Sirius XM morning mashups after  photos of Biebs facetiming her sent fans  into a wild friend  we're friends we've been friends for  years and yeah source also tells bTW the  two aren't dating and assumes the 20  year old is still with boyfriend Cameron  smaller molar share this pic with  Seinfeld just days ago the caption 3 red  rose emojis I was commenting I can use  the to look pretty smitten and not just  all social media the duo was recently  spotted at a nylon bag party during  Coachella